ISIS will survive its losses in Iraq and Syria.
It is re-establishing a haven in Libya as
a base for coordinating attacks in Europe
and operations across Africa.
ISIS operates freely in Libya’s interior
with access to lucrative smuggling and human
trafficking networks.
The threat from ISIS in Libya to Europe, and
eventually the United States, will only grow
as ISIS shifts from Iraq and Syria.
An ISIS unit in Libya facilitated the May
2017 Manchester bombing.
ISIS has also challenged Tunisia—the lone
Arab Spring success—with attacks from Libya.
The impact of military operations against
ISIS has been fleeting.
It is recovering from the loss of Sirte, its
stronghold on the Libyan coast, to US-backed
forces in late 2016.
The West cannot win against ISIS without defeating
it in Libya.
Success in Libya requires ending its civil war,
which has allowed ISIS and other terrorist groups,  including al Qaeda,
to use the country as a base for planning and conducting attacks.
What do you think is the best way to stop ISIS and al-Qaeda?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.